si le président vous appelez vous vous
lui diriez quoi avoue jean pascal et moi
déjà je le prends facetime et je lui
demande pour inverser les rôles qu'il a
voté pour moi la star ac pierre seel
présidente a peut être judicieux mais
qui fut mon numéro
[Rires]
et on reçoit une légende du cinéma
français en ce moment franchement on a
qu un entraîneur très peur depardieu
hier pierre palmade lui christophe
lambert
on joue pour une question bonus
quel a été le premier métier de
christophe lambert christophe tu ne
souffle pas non vous avez 30 secondes
pour trouver quel a été le premier
métier de christophe lambert alesi le
lit non chanteur c'est possible
le nom de castors de mouna sepehri les
cherry et goûter bien peut-être qui a la
bonne réponse lorsque vous avez dit en
fait
christophe quel était votre premier
métier vendeur de chocolat
ja
[Musique]
regardez qui est avec nous qu'a voulu
dire à mon père
j'attendais
belga sinon là est ce que tu me repasse
à paris bientôt j'espère j'espère que ça
apparaît bientôt et beaucoup de familles
normandie jeu beaucoup de match up à
paris tu présentes je sais que tu as ma
toile
je sais que tu as raté l'appel du
président emmanuel macron est ce que tu
as pu la voir derrière ou pas encore de
le rappeler je pense est très occupé
bien plus que bien plus que moi et
norman n'a pas répondu à un message et
balances ton post va revenir donc le
jeudi soir à 21h20 et vous aurez donc le
jeu à prendre ou à laisser
comment ça a très bien marché qui va
très bien voir si aujourd'hui je le son
avec charlie de minots et on suit touche
pas à mon poste avec cette équipe qui
est mais là tous les soirs qui est là
tous les soirs capi dents longues qui au
moment de cette déprogrammation comme
j'ai dit au public
je me suis posé une seule et unique
question
je tends donné qu'il y aura une heure de
plus d'émissions mon team me demander
plus d'argent oui répond je me suis dit
non non pas mais pas comme ça à nos
paroles eux non et tout le monde a dit
oui on fera cette émission une heure de
plus au même tarif
c'est pour ça que j'essaie
[Applaudissements]
bon elle
la dette
le jour 2 mois
à table
on
l'étendard
[Musique]
l'étendard sanglant ttp a été
déprogrammée
et chroniqueur ou des i/o fera les
bistrots aubaine prix avec une heure de
plus
ce club
vos chroniqueurs
[Musique]
bon comme ça mais la décision
un tonnerre d'applaudissements pour
carrick et avec les versions n'entend
pas ce que je te dis à l'époque la
question date à laquelle je vais rigoler
avec ton épaule on attend je te le dis
alors c'est tendu c'est dommage et moi
j'aimerais de bois un peu inquiet frais
que nous créons donc et loisirs du
muscle donne alors
tu crois que tu as l'air wimbledon
tu t'entraînes toujours un probant à
quoi ça sert de t'entraîner puisque tu
veux pas de mac os
moi mais je n'ai même pas besoin de deux
j'ai même pas besoin d'eux et sinon au
niveau des streaming on et comment on
rigole ans adorent toujours sans succès
mais j'ai des gens qui vont y croire
voilà j'aimerais bien moi on est hyper
pote ballon devant on adore ce vanille
commencé vraiment tout le temps sourit
avant de venir il ya même quand j'étais
convoqué donnera à fond
[Applaudissements]
non mais qu'est ce que tu aimes dans la
vie c'est qui c'est quoi tu as envie de
faire quoi s'ils arrêtent le rapstar est
de chanter on se mange fait pas rire du
tout mes chansons plus douces un petit
duo avec moi peut-être pas sympa tessia
ça me tirait mec de l'agitateur tous les
deux on fait une loi sur l'air à deux
gigas ouais il annoncé
voilà et enfin mike horn tu connais mike
horn l'aventuré ne connais pas mais je
donne je pense pas et font swing la
cyrénaïque et là tu as pauvres
[Musique]
c'est un des coups et car il peut rester
huit heures à discuter avec lui sans
savoir est-ce que tu connais caris 1
mais comme non tu veux mais celui-là
dans un truc une aventure à malek son
jogging
[Rires]
[Musique]
je suis en roi rangerait de je suis en
droit
[Musique]
bonjour
eve je suis un roi
le marché
m
bonjour je suis moi
pour cette raison j'aimerais choisir
isabelle pourquoi il est au chaud alors
accorder à monsieur retrouve et il est
où le showcase à le show case ou alors
il est où le showcase au salon du
chocolat
[Applaudissements]
les faits
vous pouvez dernière je me suis permis
d'imiter jean luc reichmann oui c'est
vrai bon et bien d'ailleurs mais j'ai un
rêve que je sais pas vous mais c'est
quoi et y a que vous qui pourrait le
réaliser c'est quoi c'est de faire une
question coquine
non et je sais que vous êtes le champion
avec jean-luc et voilà je vais pas vous
demander là aujourd'hui mais je vous
envoie la musique c'est franchement
aller
j'appelais
c'est vers l'est
non
[Applaudissements]
bien
à lezennes
[Musique]